so just wanted to check in on you how's
your progress looking with your goals
for the year is it good are you on track
are you not are you kind of discouraged
are you kind of upset with the fact that
you're not making the kind of progress
you were expecting to make uh if you're
not it's probably because what drove you
before doesn't drive you today or you
don't know what motivates you today
here's what I did once I learned what
motivated me my level of execution and
urgency went to the roof if you want to
find out what drives you I created a
quiz called pb2quiz.com click on the
link above or below go take the quiz and
find out what drives you today to get
better results